>>> WELLS
OUE SH NOWDARY OBOO
F TH LOOKS TPEVEMBER PRESIIAELEF
REPORTING COVERS TINALING TORCEA
OF
IT ALSO HAA FIRSE DEN WHDINGRER
DECISION MAKINING UPAL FROM AFG.
FEWTH
I'M TOLD THAT TH
PEALE BOOK MATERIALS, SECRET DE
JAh AND THS GOING  REVEA
WAS, AND I'ME, N JUST A DOMESTI
LITICAL AT IT WAS
ONE OF THE MT OUS
PERI
, PEL,ACTUALLY C FM N'GURATION
ERH TO I WINTE PPO
AL
GOWITH PPOSEOBAR
BOUT THAT.
NO
THEN PRESIDENT KVID.WARDEV THE
I JUSTAY ABOUT TNOT REOOK UTE QT
THOBTAIN
I WOULD SAY IGNGINOUS, AND THAT
ANN ARMY FOR TRUMP. HE W
E RD ANDVERN TT L, I IT IS -- T
PARTICULARLY WHEN YOU LOOK AT I
SO-- THERE WERE REVE
WOODWARD'S PREBOOKS.
NY
ABOUT WHAT WENT OND THE OR DURI?
>> I EXPAT HE WILL.
U KNOWODWARD
QUOTE, HHE..
THINE  SEEONE BUT SEVERAL BOMBS
FROM THIS BOOK.
>> AND WE KNOW YOU WILG
THOSE TO U JAMIE, BE